un succès diplomatique pour les uns une
trahison pour les autres l'accord de
normalisation des relations signé entre
israël et les émirats arabes unis
suscite bon nombre de réactions rendu
public sur twitter par donald trump
c'est sur ce même réseau social que le
prince héritier d'abou dhabi mohammed
ben zayed al-nahyane a confirmé
l'information
l'un des points essentiels de l'accord
la suspension de l'annexion d'une partie
des territoires palestiniens occupés
lors d'un entretien avec le président
trump et le premier ministre netanyahu
un accord a été conclu pour mettre fin à
la poursuite de l'annexion des
territoires palestiniens par israël
les émirats arabes unis et israël ont
également convenu de coopérer et
d'établir une feuille de route en vue
d'une relation bilatérale une ouverture
pour la paix selon benyamin netanyahou
le premier ministre israélien a précisé
les contours de l'entente qui doit mener
à une normalisation des relations entre
les deux états aujourd'hui une nouvelle
ère de paix commence entre israël et le
monde arabe
je viens de finir une vidéo conférence
historique avec donald trump et le
prince héritier mohammed ben zayed des
émirats arabes unis
nous avons annoncé la mise en place
d'une paix totale et formelles entre
israël et les émirats arabes unis cela
comprend l'ouverture d'ambassades
respectives des vols directs et de
nombreux autres accords bilatéraux
c'est le plus grand progrès vers la paix
entre israël et le monde arabe
ces 26 dernières années une négociation
qui prend la forme d'une victoire
stratégique sur la scène internationale
pour donald trump qui s'est rapidement
félicité de cet accord il ya quelques
instants j'ai organisé un appel très
important avec deux amis le premier
ministre israélien benyamin nétanyahou
et le prince héritier des émirats arabes
unis mohamed bin zayed où ils ont
convenu de finaliser un accord de paix
historique
tout le monde a dit que ce serait
impossible
et comme vous le savez mohamed est l'un
des grands dirigeants au moyen-orient
après 40,9 en israël les émirats arabes
unis normaliseront pleinement leurs
relations diplomatiques
un son de cloche bien différent en
revanche côté palestinien malgré des
relations souvent tendues
l'autorité palestinienne de mahmoud
abbas et le mouvement islamiste hamas
s'accordent pour dénoncer cet accord
évoquant notamment une trahison cet
accord ne sert absolument pas la cause
palestinienne ou sert but le discours
sioniste
cet accord encourage l'occupant à
persévérer dans son déni des droits du
peuple palestinien et même à continuer à
perpétrer ces crimes contre notre peuple
ce qu'il faut c'est un soutient la lutte
légitime de notre peuple
autre l'occupation non l'établissement
d'un accord avec ses occupants et nous
répondrons à toutes annexion par la
révolte des palestiniens qui ont le
soutien des arabes et de la communauté
internationale et non signant un accord
de normalisation avec lui l'autorité
palestinienne perçoit cette étape comme
un taureau en dh de l'initiative de paix
arabe des décisions des sommets arabes
et islamiques et de la loi
internationale
ainsi qu'une agression envers le peuple
palestinien et négligence des droits
inviolables palestiniens en premier lieu
de jérusalem et de l'état palestinien
indépendant selon les frontières du 4
juin 1967
l'autorité affirme que ni les émirats
arabes unis ni aucune autre partie n'a
le droit de s'exprimer au nom du peuple
palestinien et ne permet à personne
d'interférer dans les affaires
palestiniennes ou d'intervenir en leur
nom concernant les droits légitimes sur
leur terre natale
si l'accord semble évoquer une
suspension de l'annexion tant décrié sur
le plan international et benyamin
nétanyahou a spécifié qu'il ne renonçait
pas pour autant à ce projet